Hercules The Legendary Journeys was
silly campy and a lot of fun to watch
the 90s TV phenomenon earned a dedicated
worldwide fanbase generated the
successful spin-offs young Hercules and
Xena Warrior Princess let's take a look
back at the pantheon of stars from a
Hercules universe and find out where
they are today Kevin Sorbo from 1995 to
1999 Kevin Sorbo starred as the title
character of Hercules
The Legendary Journeys in the show
Hercules had ventured through ancient
Europe confronting evil beings and other
challenges along the way despite facing
challenges with his personal health like
the three strokes he suffered because of
an aneurysm in his shoulder servo has
continued acting starring in projects
like the sie Clyde drama series
Andromeda from 2000 and 2005 more
recently Sabo had a reoccurring role in
the CW series Super Girl
Annie's lined up nearly a dozen films
for release in 2017 and 2018
Michael Hirst New Zealand native Michael
Herz co-starred in The Legendary
Journeys as I olace friend and sidekick
to Hercules like Sorbo Hurst reprise his
role in a few episodes of the Hercules
spin-off show Xena Warrior Princess he's
continued acting from circulates he's
also turned his attention to writing and
directing he's recently directed
episodes of ash vs. Evil Dead and the
New Zealand show Westside Lucy Lawless
which started out as a guest role and
Hercules The Legendary Journeys turned
into a career-making move for Lucy
Lawless when she was given her own
spin-off series Xena Warrior Princess
Wallace has maintained a successful
acting career since then appearing in
dozens of films and shows notably she
guest-starred in 16 episodes of
Battlestar Galactica and in the star
series Spartacus lawless also had a
reoccurring role on Parks and Recreation
and a major part on ash vs. Evil Dead
Robert rebirth when Hercules wasn't
partner with Eolas for an adventure he
frequently traveled with the crafty
salesman Salmoneus played by Robert
reamer Schreiber has continued to appear
in television shows and on the big
screen
Landing a list of parts that include
guest roles in boomtown and the Devil's
Rejects
most recently Schreiber played the
producer in the 2016 Coen brothers
comedy Hail Caesar Jeffrey Thomas for
sixteen episodes of Hercules Jeffrey
Thomas played the legendary ruler King
Jason Thomas later appeared as titus in
the star series Spartacus and the dwarf
King Thor in The Hobbit can unexpected
journey in 2015 he starred in the horror
film the dead
more recently Thomas appeared the light
between oceans alongside Alicia vikander
and Michael Fassbender Kevin Todd Smith
Zeeland actor Kevin Todd Smith landed a
major reoccurring role on hercules and
xena spinoff as Ares the God of War
between the two shows he starred in over
50 episodes often filming for both
productions at the same time
Smith seemed to have a promising career
ahead of him and was cast to appear in
the Bruce Willis war drama tears of the
Sun but he passed away before he could
film the part Smith accidentally fell
from a prop tower and suffered major
injuries which led to his death on
February 15 2002 Bruce Campbell although
he's much better known for his role as
ash in the Evil Dead franchise Bruce
Campbell starred in The Legendary
Journeys and Xena Warrior Princess as
Autolycus the self-proclaimed king of
thieves who occasionally assists
hercules and xena on their adventures
Campbell was also an executive producer
for Hercules Campbell's appeared in
dozens of films and television shows in
the years since most recently he
returned to his roots by starring in the
Starz comedy action series ash vs. Evil
Dead
Alexandra tidings for 10 episodes of
Hercules and 11 episodes of Xena
Alexandra Tydings played Aphrodite a
Greek goddess of love and half sister of
Hercules
despite the dumb blonde stereotype she
portrayed as Aphrodite
tithings is one smart cookie she largely
retired from acting after Xena and
turned her attention to writing and
directing Gina Torres while she's better
known these days for a roller Zooey and
Firefly many fans will remember Gina
Torres as the pirate nebula from
Hercules Torres has had a strong
Hollywood career sent for Julie's
Landing major roles in 24 Lea patro 2525
and aeleus more recently she appeared in
the ABC series the catch and provided
the voice of I Cora rain the video game
destiny to joel Toback while he
primarily played the Greek gods strife
in The Legendary Journeys Joe Lobeck
also appeared as Stripes cousin Deimos
in both hercules and xena
in addition to a significant role in
Sons of Anarchy tel back later reunited
with several of his cast mates for other
projects including Bruce Campbell and
Lucy Lawless and ash vs. Evil Dead
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Applause]
[Music]